by now everybody acknowledges that the
federal government lies to Americans as
a matter of course it's no longer just
the so-called conspiracy theorists who
think that anyone who's been paying
attention over the last couple of
decades has come to that conclusion
after covid after the recession that
wasn't really a recession because they
changed the definition of a recession
after the wars in Iraq and Syria and
Afghanistan and Ukraine and so on
there's no reasonable person left in
this country who trusts the federal
government on faith and rightfully so
what this means is that if you're a
Washington bureaucrat tolling away in
say Joe Biden's justice department you
have to adapt you you can't just feed
people bald-faced propaganda because no
one will buy it you have to work to sell
the deception so naturally that's
exactly what the doj has been doing
they're coming up with inventive new
ways to lie that are difficult to detect
at least on the surface
so here's one example that went totally
unreported by the mainstream press Kevin
Benjamin Ware is a California man in his
mid-30s now during the canonization of
Saint George Floyd three years ago where
took it upon himself to light a federal
courthouse in Portland on fire and
there's no dispute about that we're
pleaded guilty to quote repositioning a
piece of lit wood against the walls of
the courthouse in other words trying to
set it on fire and where wasn't the only
one who tried that tactic in case you've
forgotten there were mobs of people
sieging this courthouse and trying to
burn it down here's some footage from
that occasion just to refresh your
memory well
[Music]
[Applause]
oh yeah
[Music]
foreign
Benjamin Ware was one of a handful of
militants who was involved in all of
that chaos and was arrested after this
attack on the federal courthouse after
wear pleaded guilty Joe Biden's doj made
a point to issue a press release about
the many years in jail this domestic
terrorist was facing specifically the
doj's press release stated that where is
intentional destruction of the federal
courthouse was quote punishable by up to
10 years in prison
admittedly 10 years in prison is a
little light for trying to torch a
federal courthouse with people inside of
it but at least it's something you know
it's it's uh it's a long sentence long
enough you might think to deter other
Californians from trekking to Portland
for the purpose of burning down
courthouses what's interesting is that
Joe Biden's doj Never released a
follow-up press release after where it
was actually sentenced they sent the
message this arsonist would serve some
hard time there would be a stiff
punishment but they failed to inform the
public about what wears actual sentence
was
why is that well it's not hard to answer
that question as it happens where
ultimately received a sentence that was
nowhere near the 10-year term that
Biden's doj suggested he might serve
instead on the recommendation of federal
prosecutors where received a sentence of
two years probation
for trying to set a federal courthouse
on fire he got two years probation
and indeed Kevin Ware never served a day
in prison
he did have to pay a 200 fine though so
there's that 200 bucks you know like a
like a speeding ticket
if you're a former GOP Congressional
candidate by the name of Enrique atario
this is all very confusing because
Enrique atario was just sentenced to 22
years in prison this happened yesterday
for his quote involvement on January 6th
prosecutors had sought a 33-year
sentence for tario but the judge brought
them down a little bit and now it's only
only 22 years what was Enrique atario's
crime well he didn't try to set fire to
the Capitol Building on January 6th he
didn't try to burn down any federal
courthouses unlike Kevin Ware he didn't
he didn't place a flaming piece of wood
up against a federal building
we know that because on January 6th
Enrique tario was nowhere near any
federal building
he had been arrested for vandalizing a
holy BLM Banner a few days earlier
and was ordered by a judge to stay far
away from Washington DC so he was not
there
nonetheless yesterday tario received the
single longest sentence of any January
6th defendant uh watch this
Denise and Christie a federal judge
handing down the sentence to Enrique
atario 22 years in prison for seditious
conspiracy in connection to the January
6th Capital attack as you mentioned he's
the former proud boys leader from right
here in South Florida he was found
guilty of orchestrating the riot from
members at the far right extreme of the
far-right extremist group he was not
actually in Washington the day of the
attack but prosecutors say he was the
ringleader prosecutors were initially
seeking 33 years which is the longest
sentence instead giving him 22 years
related to the capital attack he's the
last of five proud boys defendants to be
sentenced he and three other members
were also found guilty of seditious
conspiracy and before the sentencing he
spoke he apologized for the quote pain
and suffering that law enforcement
legislators and others suffered on
January 6th and vowed to have nothing to
do with politics groups activism or
rallies so again a federal judge
sentencing Enrique Tarios from right
here in South Florida to 22 years in
prison for seditious conspiracy
it's a it's a surreal news report in a
lot of ways for one thing neither the
reporter nor the two anchors uh who uh
who were on the report as well seem
remotely concerned by the fact that
Enrique tario was just sent us to 22
years in prison for orchestrating
quote-unquote a riot that he didn't even
attend there's no discussion whatsoever
about what tario might have done or how
exactly he facilitated what happened on
January 6 when he wasn't even there
nobody cares
so let's talk about it according to the
government tario told his followers on
January 6 to quote do what must be done
he also told members of The Proud boys
to organize a big crowd in Washington to
storm government buildings the scheme
was known as 1776 returns
now sounds pretty ominous right storming
government buildings where have we seen
something like that before
well if you're not a goldfish or a fruit
fly and your memory extends longer than
a few seconds you know the answer to
that question here's what the Supreme
Court and the capital complex looked
like during the Kavanaugh hearings watch
these are live images Folks at
the doors of the Supreme Court where you
can see protesters have gathered they
are demanding
that their voices be heard as they
anticipate
who will what who the person who will be
a new Supreme Court Justice judge Brett
Kavanaugh be sworn in here any moment in
a bigger picture you can see
approximately how many people who have
gathered there looks like there are
dozens and they are chanting so people
were arrested in Washington over the
last few hours for illegally protesting
inside the Senate Office Building over
Kavanaugh's nomination comedian and
actor Amy Schumer as well as model Emily
ratakowski were among them the
protesters originally planned to protest
on the capitol steps but headed inside
the senate for a sit-in U.S Capitol
Police say everyone arrested were
processed and then released
so these people bang on the doors of the
Supreme Court they storm a senate office
building and their punishment is
absolutely nothing they got zip tied at
most and then let go immediately
their explicit purpose was to derail a
government proceeding it was to
interfere with the government proceeding
in fact some of these activists uh you
know charged into the the Senate
chambers themselves
none of them suffered any real
consequences in fact left-wing activists
who have committed acts of violence even
homicides have received far more lenient
sentences than Enrique atario just did
because consider the case of the BLM
arsonist back in 2020 Who lit a pawn
shop on fire in the name of civil rights
three days after Saint George Floyd
overdosed Montes T Lee decided to commit
an act of arson that killed someone by
the name of Oscar Lee Stewart Stewart's
body wasn't found in the rubble for
nearly two months
what was uh Montez Lee's sentence he got
less than 10 years in prison
for an arson that again killed someone
that's less than half the sentence that
Enrique atario will face for sending
some you know naughty text messages is
your cell phone in desperate need of
replacement you know the signs short
battery life you have to have a charger
on hand cracked screen that gives you
glass splinters it's time to put that
old phone to rest and upgrade to a new
5G Samsung Galaxy from Pure Talk for
free get a free 5G Samsung Galaxy with
two day battery life edged Edge display
an ultra strong Gorilla Glass when you
sign up for Pure talks unlimited talk
text and 15 gig data plan for just 35 a
month plus it comes with a mobile
hotspot on top of all that get all the
data you could ever need for half the
price of the big carriers on America's
Most Dependable 5G Network go to
puretalk.com Walsh for your free super
durable 5G Samsung Galaxy when you
switch to pure talk again visit
puretalk.com Walsh and make the switch
to my cell phone company Pure Talk the
official Wireless partner of the daily
wire
as you might know we're all uh fans of
our friends at genucel here don't just
take my word for it though Ella from
Rockford says quote I have both age and
acne spots and this stuff is actually
fading both of them this Serum is worth
every penny Ella's raving out the famous
Dark Spot Corrector from genocell which
they must have after months of record
heat and humidity sun spots brown spots
discoloration even red inflamed patches
all disappear in front of your very eyes
and here's the genocell amazing
guarantee you'll see results on day one
or your money back you know who has a
lot of dark spots my producer Sean uh he
also has an upsetting amount of acne
just like he doesn't know how to cook a
marshmallow he doesn't know how to take
care of his skin as well he is a
disgusting monster and I would tell him
in fact he's sitting right over there
right now he's listening to this and he
needs to hear it's someone needed to
talk about it anyway now he's using
geniusell thank God and he's no longer
completely hideous he's only partially
hideous so take advantage of geniusell's
most popular package which now includes
the Dark Spot Corrector plus the classic
genucel bags and puffiness treatment and
immediate effects you get all of that at
about 70 off so you can try the best
skin care in the world yourself for
completely risk-free it's simple go to
genyourself.com Walsh you'll start
looking years even decades younger
tomorrow say goodbye to dark and liver
spot bags and puffiness under the eyes
and crow's feet at genucel.com Walsh
that's genucel.com Walsh
now I'm focusing on Enrique atario here
because his sentence is the most
egregious but there's many more examples
of this obviously unequal Justice we're
seeing consider the case of Joseph Biggs
he's a a man with no criminal record
whatsoever Biggs is an army veteran who
didn't hurt anybody on January 6 but he
did walk around the Capitol building on
January 6th and he did also help to pull
down a fence on the periphery of the
building
and for that judge Tim Kelly the same
judge who sentenced tario decided that
Joseph Biggs needs to spend 17 years in
prison
for walking around the Capitol building
and pulling down a fence
17 years
now again you may ask yourself where
have we seen political demonstrators
ripping apart fences in front of
government buildings before oh well
that's right we saw it during the BLM
riots that torched Saint John's Church
across the street from the White House
send Donald Trump into a bunker
they were tearing down fencing they were
setting a church on fire and and yet
nobody involved in any of that was ever
frog marched in front of the cameras or
sentenced to 22 years in prison
in fact it doesn't appear that anyone
involved in that incident or the burning
of St John's Church spent a day in
federal prison
we see relatively light or non-existent
sentences like this all the time a
Serial child rapist in Ohio just got 10
years in prison only 10 years for serial
child rape a drunk driver in Phoenix
said four times the the legal uh blood
alcohol limit just got 12 years in
prison for driving 135 miles per hour
and killing someone
a terrorist train engineer Los Angeles
who tried to run his locomotive into a
U.S Navy hospital ship during covid
received just three years in prison
a man who burned down a Minneapolis
Police Station live on National
Television during the George Floyd riots
received four years in prison
four years
for burning down a police station
there are police still inside by the way
they went running for their lives four
years for that 22 years for Enrique
Targa
another man who lit a Molotov cocktail
and threw it at the police station got
just three years in prison so you get
the idea
on the other hand anyone remotely
involved in January 6 including
non-violent offenders is being hunted
down right now we're talking about
American citizens well over two years
after January 6 who are being ambushed
out of nowhere by heavily armed FBI
agents playing hero
this is how the FBI just approached one
small business owner in Arkansas named
Nathan Hughes who uh they hunted down
track down outside of his business and
here's what that looked like
okay watch out watch out
[Music]
hey
who is it
you work here
he's one of the owners
so you've got heavily armed agents
surrounding Nathan Hughes and dragging
away in handcuffs in the in the broad
daylight in front of uh you know in
front of his business
what was Nathan hughes's crime well
according to the doj he wore an infowar
shirt while pushing against the police
line at the Capitol
and to be clear if Nathan Hughes
actually did push against the police
line on January 6th that's a crime it'd
be comparable to the crime that BLM BLM
Riders committed uh when they you know
when in the footage that we've seen and
then push against police lines although
in many cases they did quite a bit more
than that for them pushing involved like
throwing bricks and that sort of thing
at officers heads
but Nathan use case is not being handled
remotely the same way as those BLM
writers
Nathan Hughes didn't get off without any
consequence whatsoever and studies now
facing more than five years in prison on
felony civil disorder charges
the FED showed up to arrest him with
body armor and rifles and full view of
customers as if he was some kind of a
terrorist
in fact the feds also rated hughes's
home and opened his safe and the company
Liberty say for some incomprehensible
reason complied with the fed's demands
and used a backdoor mechanism to open
the safe for them
now there's no conceivable argument I
can possibly justify all of this for the
simple reason that nothing remotely like
this has ever happened to left-wing
terrorists like antifa or BLM
none of those thugs have ever received
anything like this treatment even when
they murder people
now if we lived in a country in which
every you know law breaker however
that's defined faced extremely harsh
punishment that's the kind of country we
lived in or if you break any law at all
you can be guaranteed they're going to
throw the book at you
if that's the country we lived in then
maybe the treatment of the January
Sixers would be tolerable because it
would be consistent
that's how the rule of law is supposed
to work it's supposed to guarantee equal
punishment for equal crimes
so if we lived in a country where if you
participated in any Riot whatsoever you
can guarantee that the cops are going to
hunt you down and they're going to throw
you in prison for as long as they
possibly can
if we live in that kind of country
but we don't live in that kind of
country
most criminals are treated with kid
gloves even the most violent and
dangerous kinds
it's only with Trump supporters and
Trump himself and other political
dissidents that suddenly suddenly we
become a land of strict enforcement and
merciless punishment that's the point
that's been made again and again over
the past couple of years As Trump
supporters are sent to prison for memes
as U.S service members are dismissed for
refusing to take the coveted shot and so
on but the prosecution of people like
Enrique atario and Nathan Hughes marks
an escalation in the bite
administration's tactics same goes for
the Biden doj's handling of the raid on
Craig Robinson a few months ago or
rather a month ago Robertson was the
elderly invalid Trump supporter in Utah
who shared threatening memes about Joe
Biden on social media for months weeks
later instead of picking up Robertson
while he was on his motorized scooter at
Walgreens or something which would be
very easy to do the FBI decided to
surprise Robertson with a 6 a.m raid at
his home for the memes that he posted on
Facebook
and they shot him in the process and
killed him they say after he had raised
a pistol and that's why they shot him
now did he actually raise a pistol maybe
he did we don't really know we reached
out to the FBI to obtain the body cam
footage from The Raid yesterday the FBI
refused to provide it citing ongoing
enforcement proceedings
that justification of course makes no
sense because they've already killed the
70-something-year-old man who was
posting the memes that they were so
concerned about but the FBI said it
anyway because they're confident that
nobody in mainstream media will look
into it any further and none of them are
and on that point if we're being honest
the FBI is probably right
we may have actually reached the point
where the Federal Government Can
imprison and even kill its political
enemies without any oversight
even if it's either even as it gives a
pass to terrorists on their side of the
political Spectrum which is what they're
doing
if that's the case then we don't have a
society that's governed by the rule of
law anymore
we have a society that like every
dictatorship enforces the will of the
ruling class with raw power
you hate to think that's what we're
dealing with right now but unless a real
opposition forms a less conservatives
start electing leaders who are ready and
equipped to deal with this problem for
starters
then it will be our future
there's no question about that
thanks for checking out this video if
you'd like to listen to my full podcast
on the go you can check out the Matt
wall show on Apple podcast Spotify or
wherever you get your podcasts